ya reclaman una voz real en el diálogo
tras dos semanas de protestas contra su
gobierno del presidente colombiano iván
duque inició conversaciones con
representantes de varios sectores
sociales aunque los manifestantes
denuncian que siguen siendo ignorados
que están haciéndose un juego con el
pueblo colombiano no quieren escuchar lo
que es las peticiones del pueblo que ya
nos cansamos de la ave rancia del estado
colombiano que lo único que hace es
maltratar nos y agredirnos con balas con
disparos con gases con cárcel con
muertes y con desapariciones es el
comité nacional del paro aseguran
asimismo que no hay condiciones de
negociación le hemos solicitado el
comité de paro al presidente como
comandante de las fuerzas armadas que
pare la masacre que hay contra los
jóvenes en colombia que desmilitariza la
protesta social
que no permita el uso de armas letales
en la protesta social por parte del
esmad
sin estas condiciones sin garantías es
imposible negociar el pliego de
emergencia que le presentamos hace un
año al presidente
remarcan también que los motivos de la
protesta siguen existiendo 17 millones
de personas que se acuestan con hambre
21 millones de personas que es el 40 por
ciento de la población en pobreza
cerca del 10% de la población en extrema
pobreza que gana menos de un dólar y
medio diario otros señalan avances una
cosa importante en la visita del
presidente ayer y es que escucho que
escucho a la gente que estuvo con él
pidiéndole que esto no sea una solución
armada sino de diálogo
que acepto ayer mismo empezar la misa de
negociación pero en cali epicentro de
las protestas los manifestantes exigen
que el viernes el presidente y los
gobiernos locales acudan en persona a
escucharlos por primera vez